all across China people are celebrating
the Lunar New Year and beginning of the
year of the rabbit with dragon dancing
Temple fairs and Red Lanterns it's the
first time since the beginning of the
pandemic people are allowed to gather
and enjoy these Chinese traditions
in Beijing many queued for hours to pray
at Lama Temple the most important
Buddhist site in the capital city
it's reopened after strict coronavirus
controls kept it shut for three years
I am really very happy I haven't seen
such a busy scene with so many people
for a long time this is the real
atmosphere of the Lunar New Year
after all the restrictions were lifted
people became more relaxed we went
through a lot of difficult times during
the pandemic
many are really the days of coronavirus
lockdowns are behind them
last year was the year of the tiger and
according to Chinese zodiac it carried
with it qualities of disruption and
restlessness and that certainly ran true
for many here whose lives were
negatively impacted by China's zero
covert policy and now it's the new year
year of the rabbit and thousands have
come to this Temple to pray for a more
prosperous and positive year going
forward
last year Festival Banquets were
forbidden now hotels and restaurants are
booked out others Feast at home enjoying
handmade dumplings and noodles families
kept apart by years of travel bans have
finally been reunited
an annual Gala aired by China State
broadcaster included much singing and
dancing but masks were nowhere to be
seen coronavirus infections surged after
the sudden lifting of restrictions in
December
at least 70 000 people have died but
while some are mourning others believe
the most difficult time has passed in
days with many wishing for Good Fortune
and good health over the coming 12
months Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing